ACCORDING TO A SOURCE, THE
SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO CAME AFTER
AUTHORITIES BELIEVED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OR HIS TEAM FAILED TO
RETURN MATERIALS THAT WERE
GOVERNMENT PROPERTY, AND IT WAS
BELIEVED THE DOCUMENTS HAD
NATIONAL SECURITY IMPLICATIONS.
NOW, THE SEARCH WARRANT
PERTAINED TO BOTH THE HANDLING
OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT.
THE LAW WAS ESTABLISHED AFTER
PRESIDENT NIXON'S WATERGATE
SCANDAL.
NOW, IN ANOTHER HISTORICAL
PARALLEL, THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH
CAME ON THE 48th ANNIVERSARY OF
NIXON'S RESIGNATION.
MEANTIME, IN A STATEMENT
YESTERDAY, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
PROCEEDED TO KIND OF MANGLE
WATERGATE HISTORY.
QUOTING NOW, WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE, HE SAID, BETWEEN
THIS AND WATERGATE WHERE
OPERATIVES BROKE INTO THE
DEMOCRAT NATIONAL COMMITTEE?
HERE NOW IN REVERSE, DEMOCRATS
BROKE INTO THE HOME OF THE 45th
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
JOINING US NOW, CARL BERNSTEIN,
ALSO FORMER NIXON WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL JOHN DEAN.
CARL, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION
FIRST OF ALL TO THE SEARCH AND
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM PEOPLE
IN THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S ORBIT?
>> WELL, FIRST, THIS IS A DEADLY
SERIOUS MATTER.
IN THE VIEW OF EVEN FORMER TOP
OFFICIALS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
I SPOKE TODAY TO ONE OF THE
SENIOR MOST INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS THROUGHOUT THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY, AND THE POINT HE
MADE WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT THESE
MATERIALS ARE IS THAT IT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE IN HIS VIEW
THAT THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WOULD TAKE THIS
ACTION WITHOUT KNOWLEDGE OR
BELIEF THAT THE MATERIALS
CONTAINED THE MOST SENSITIVE
NATIONAL SECURITY INFORMATION,
OF REAL MAGNITUDE, THAT THIS
COULD NOT BE DONE UNLESS THERE
WAS REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COULD BE
GRIEVOUSLY INJURED IF THESE
DOCUMENTS GOT OUT.
IT'S NOT JUST IN THIS PERSON'S
VIEW, BUT IT'S SPECULATIVE THAT
THIS WOULD BE ABOUT THE LAWYERS
NOT BEING TOTALLY TRUTHFUL BUT,
RATHER, NOT BEING TRUTHFUL OR
THAT THERE IS KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT NOW HAS THAT WHAT IS
BEING WITHHELD IS OF SERIOUS,
SERIOUS IMPORTANCE.
>> JOHN, WAS THIS A REVERSE
WATERGATE BREAK-IN AS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS SAYING?
>> NOT EVEN CLOSE, ANDERSON.
THIS WAS AUTHORIZED.
IT WAS AN AUTHORIZED COURT
PROCEEDING TO SEARCH AND SEIZE
MATERIALS, AND OBVIOUSLY AS CARL
SAYS, THEY WERE IMPORTANT
MATERIALS.
WA
WATERGATE WAS A BUNGLED BREAK-IN
BY A BUNCH OF ACTUALLY CLOWNS IN
A WAY IN THEIR EFFORT TO GET
INTO THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE AND REPAIR A BUG AND
TAKE SOME PHOTOGRAPHS AFTER
HAVING BEEN EARLIER IN THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
VERY DIFFERENT PARALLELS.
AND TRUMP REFERRING TO
WATERGATE, OF COURSE, FOCUSES ON
THE BREAK-IN.
AND WATER GAMEGATE BECAME SO MU
MORE THAN A BUNGLED BREAK-IN.
IT BECAME A COVER-UP.
IT BECAME AN ABUSE OF PRESOWER.
>> I THINK THAT THEY'RE BOTH
VERY PRINCIPLED, AND LEADERS IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AFTER
NIXON FIRED -- IN THE SATURDAY
NIGHT MASSACRE, HE FIRED THE
LEADERS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, AND THOSE LEADERS
WERE PURSUING THE CASE AGAINST
NIXON WITH GREAT INDEPENDENCE.
SIMILARLY, MERRICK GARLAND HERE
IS TRYING TO FOLLOW, AS FAR AS
WE KNOW, WHERE THE LEADS GO WITH
SUGGESTIONS, AND PROBABLY MORE
THAN SUGGESTIONS, THAT A CRIME
HAS BEEN COMMITTED.
HE WOULD NEVER HAVE DONE THIS
UNLESS THERE WERE EVIDENCE OF A
CRIME HAVING BEEN COMMITTED AND
BY DONALD TRUMP AND THOSE AROUND
HIM.
AND SIMILARLY IN WATERGATE, YOU
HAD THE SITUATION WHERE THE
OFFICIALS WHO WERE FIRED BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAD SIMILAR BELIEFS ABOUT WHERE
THE CASE WAS GOING AGAINST
RICHARD NIXON AND THE COVER-UP.
>> JOHN, DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
JUST SEARCHING FOR, YOU KNOW,
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAY HAVE TAKEN FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN HE LEFT
WOULD BE ENOUGH FOR THE FBI TO
DECIDE TO DO THIS?
>> IT DEPENDS UPON THE CONTENT
OF THE DOCUMENTS.
THERE COULD BE SOME VERY SE
SERIOUSLY COMPROMISABLE MATERIAL
AND NATIONAL SECURITY DATA,
BLUEPRINTS.
WHO KNOWS WHAT IS THERE?
BUT THERE ARE EVEN DOCUMENTS
APPARENTLY THAT ARE SO HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED THAT THEIR
CLASSIFICATION IS CLASSIFIED.
SO THEY CAN'T EVEN LIST SOME OF
THE MATERIAL THAT THEY HAVE
ACQUIRED IN THIS SEARCH.
SO, YES, I THINK THERE CAN BE
STUFF THAT CAN AFFECT THE UNITED
STATES.
IT CAN SHOW SOURCES AND METHODS.
NATIONAL SECURITY HAS LONG BEEN
AN AREA OF PARTICULAR ATTENTION,
AND THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES, SINCE
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT,
HAS BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
GOING AFTER FORMER STAFF, NEVER
TO REACH A PRESIDENT BEFORE, BUT
FORMER STAFF OR PEOPLE, VERY
SENIOR POLITICAL PEOPLE.
SANDY BERGER, WHO WAS THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER IN THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION.
GENERAL PETRAEUS WHO WAS WRITING
A BOOK.
THEY'VE ALL EXPERIENCED WHAT
HAPPENS IF YOU MISUSE CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL.
AND SO THIS IS NOT
UNPRECEDENTED.
IT HAS JUST NEVER REACHED A
PRESIDENT EVER ABUSING HIS POWER
AND TAKING MATERIAL LIKE THIS
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
>> JOHN DEAN, CARL BERNSTEIN,
THANK YOU.